parmi les ennemis les plus dangereux il
ya ceux qui placent leur religion au
dessus des lois de la république et ceux
qui placent leurs convictions politiques
au dessus des lois de la république
c'est le cas de génération identitaire
qui se comporte comme une milice comme
une milice autoproclamé c'est à dire qui
se place au dessus de nos lois au dessus
de la police j'ai pas terminé au dessus
des gardes frontières alors pour le
moment ce sont juste des zozos parce
qu'il faut dire que les gendarmes sont
intervenus parce que comme il n'était
pas équipé les gendarmes avaient peur
qu'ils attrapent des engelures parce que
c'est des zozos
mais on a vu au capitole à washington ce
que ça peut donner ça sorte quoi on ne
faisait pas les zozos comme génération
identitaire un jour ça donne des gens
armés assurent contestent le scrutin
mais puller tournoi c'est pas le cas
pour me prononcer sur la question qui
nous a été posée
je demande je souhaite leur dissolution
avant que les zozos deviennent plus
dangereux mais alors en général sur
internet on va voir leurs actions les
plus connus vous êtes fait connaître
notamment après une action la mosquée de
poitiers en 2012 ils ont occupé pendant
des heures le chantier réclamer un
référendum sur la construction de
mosquées et sur l'immigration regarder
l'occupation de la grande mosquée de
poitiers a duré toute la matinée
soixante treize militants ont investi
les lieux en construction aux alentours
de 6 heures du matin en milieu de
matinée les forces de l'ordre ont fait
appel aux pompiers et à leur grande
échelle pour engager le dialogue avec
les militants et je ne peux être
abasourdi par une telle action contre on
s'attendait pas à cela
alors yassine belattar nous a rejoint
merci yacine qui vient de chez lui des
maps et iliad est à jeter un bris jama
ouais et on m'a dit une ratonnade
je pense qu'effectivement le problème de
génération identitaire c'est qu'en fait
ils desservent une cause qu'ils seraient
censés défendre
oui il ya un problème avec l'immigration
en france très clairement on n'arrive
pas à gérer l'immigration mais c'est pas
un groupuscule
d'hystérique qui vont sur la montagne en
4/4 d'aller faire éventuellement
appliquer la loi c'est à dire ne pas
faire rentrer des étrangers illégalement
parce que dans ces cas là et c'est là
haut mais j'en mets siens ne peut être
que d'accord puisque c'est l'extrême
droite c'est le flou non vraiment
nationale je ne vois aucune différence
alors que tous ces gens là votre
assemblée nationale et madame le pen
doit être très content de pouvoir vous
recrutez éventuel là il ya aucune
différence va demander si en france on
se perd mais monsieur mais si y'a comme
vous de rappeler tous les jours aux
français qu'ils doivent respecter la loi
s'il vous plaît n'allez pas mirage et
des gens qui jouent au football
madame ça y est c'est jean violas loire
aident les migrants ce duel doit il ya
une loi du séjour il ya une loi de
l'entrée sur le territoire français qui
est bafouée foulé aux pieds tous les
jours c'est déjà lancé nick ne l'est pas
râler de celle qui est violet bon son